some are celebrating the beauty of the
season as you saw others are warning of
one of the dangers of wintertime the flu
according to the CDC flu activity is now
high in 34 states it hasn't been this
widespread this early in the season in
more than a decade
an estimated 29 hundred people have died
dr. Jon LaPook has more on what's being
done to contain the outbreak at Riley
Hospital for Children in Indianapolis
fighting flu begins at the front door
we're just trying to take extra
precautions the hospital has created
influenza checkpoints where security
keeps a list of approved visitors mostly
parents dr. Elaine Cox is an infectious
disease specialist even when they visit
and they're on the list they're screened
for illness so fever or cough runny nose
body aches the goal create a ring of
protection around vulnerable kids that's
especially important to De'Anthony nitin
and his ten-year-old son D Anthony
junior who's on kidney dialysis his
immune system is a lot weaker with his
condition so making sure that we are all
vaccinated is very important to make
sure he stays at a hundred percent what
is health the CDC reported there have
been more than 55,000 hospitalizations
this flu season usually the predominant
strain is influenza A but this year it's
been influenza B so far what comes next
is anyone's guess Lynette Brammer is
with the CDC we'll have to wait and see
what happens in the coming weeks even if
we are at peak we still have half of the
flu season to go and there may be other
viruses circulating after the influenza
B's that are here right now it's still
too early to say how effective this
year's influenza vaccine will end up
being but with the flu season occurring
earlier than usual and accelerating the
CDC is reminding people it's not too
late to get immunized
for CBS this morning Saturday dr. Jon
LaPook New York immaculee 'td I finally
did it
for you there you go know a lot of
people but you people are building
another flu I mean it it's it is not
pretty have you gotten yeah okay in like
super early Jeff yeah Bryan Applegate
[Laughter]
you